[Musik]
was gestern schon wieder so betrunken
ein alter was eine ananas ausgelöffelt
und geschrien ich weiß dass du da drin
bis spongebob
und damit herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einer weiteren episode ihr schreibt
jemand seinem kollegen hey du hast dein
handy bei mir vergessen hallo schreibt x
na dann halt netz wahrscheinlich sieht
er diese nachrichten wenn sein handy
noch bei dir liegt als nächstes haben
wir einen gruppenchat und verstärkern du
bist so süß daraufhin antwortet mandy er
kann du bist viel süßer nein niemals du
bist hier süß hat du bist der süße du
bist aber viel süßer du bist so süß dass
mir kein spruch ein feld und dann kommt
der ehren bruders herr kann dazu und
schreibt einfach haltet eure presse seit
beide hässlich der stelle muss ich wegen
einer noch sagen ihre genommen die ampel
ist so süß wie so immer wenn sie mich
sieht wird sie dem rekord wie kommt man
auf so eine gequälte kaka sag mal wie
führt man hierbei whatsapp leute auf den
kontakt gehen dann zu optionen mehr und
dann blockieren hat es geklappt hat
er hat dich blockiert das gibt es bei
dir zu essen war get wet wet wet mir
egal langes brot aus frankreich hier
würde ich tatsächlich das hier empfehlen
als nächstes bekommt jemand die frage
liebst du mich gestellt und seine
antwort ist nicht einfach irgendwie hey
aus dem grund oder jahr aus dem grund
sondern er antwortet ja bestehend aus
nur ich bin verwirrt hältst du die zahl
der liebe nein du 26 1893 woher weißt du
dass wenn sich zwei menschen lieben und
sex sex haben und nicht achtgeben sind
sie nach neun monate heilige scheiße ich
will geistig nicht ganz gesund im
nächsten whatsapp fälle hat sich ein
vater whatsapp runtergeladen und bekommt
die nachrichten von seinem kind endlich
hast du auch ein smartphone papa wie ist
es denn so hallo papa warum antwortest
du nicht und daraufhin schreibt der
vater einfach wie geht ein leerzeichen
wir sind letztes viel zu schnell durch
die ortschaft
fahren dabei sind die mithin in eine
polizeikontrolle gekommen aha und dann
wie kommt man auf so eine scheiße
besaßen nur auf dem beifahrersitz bei
der übels bereit war was macht er knapp
das handschuhfach auf und ruft brücke an
maschinenraum weniger kohle wie
wahnsinnig wenn dummheit weh tun würde
wohin gehe ich verstehe es endlich was
denn du weißt ja wenn sachen heißen
denen sie sich aus ja und ich bin nicht
ich bin heiß ich will mir die letzten
fünf gar nicht mehr durch lesen was
willst du mal werden millionär wie mein
vater was omg dein vater ist millionär
nein er will auch millionär werden
und was machst du so in deiner freizeit
ich stocke gerne cool ich gehe schwimmen
ich weiß jeden mittwoch um 16 uhr 45 der
mission menschenrechte sind ziemlich
abstoßend uhu ich war mit meiner mama
einkaufen das klingt ja nach totaler
begeisterung naja ich glaube sie hat 20
amputiert rosen an proviant die
autokorrektur mal wieder man kennt sie
im nächsten whatsapp fälle hat die
freundinnen des users geburtstag und er
schreibt das sollte eigentlich eine
überraschung sein aber hast du dich an
den pinken mercedes den er unbedingt
wollte ist omg omg omg ja ich schreibe
gerade ich habe ja eine zahnbürste
gekauft gleiche farbe ich glaube du bist
jetzt single wien bringen allerdings nur
doch schon zum letzten wort fällt für
die heutige episode ich weiß ich weiß
ich heute auch innerlich irgendwo freue
ich mich aber auch dann haben meine
gehirnzellen die dann eine pause
in dem ortsteil geht's auf jeden fall
darum dass sich eine mutter zum ersten
mal runtergeladen hat um zum ersten mal
dort die sprachfunktion getestet hat und
dann geschrieben hat halo leertaste sven
leertaste ausrufezeichen leertaste
großbuchstaben was leertaste macht
leertaste die leertaste uni
fragezeichen smiley
an der stelle würde ich einfach nur noch
sagen falls leerzeichen euch leerzeichen
mein leerzeichen heutiges leerzeichen
video leerzeichen gefallen leerzeichen
hat dann meine lieben freunde jetzt hab
ich die leerzeichen vergessen lassen
aber hoch bei diesem video ihr da
schreibt mir und in die kommentare ab
nächste woche ein weiterer teil whatsapp
fans kommen soll und abonniert main
kanal falls sie noch kein teil von
meiner unfall sollen die seitlich unter
dem video auf abonnieren oder ich
schmeiße 4000 tomaten auf
[Musik]